steelers traded away antonio brown for a
lot less a three and a five the raiders
introduced antonio brown on wednesday
and
here is what antonio brown said when he
was asked during the press conference
what he brings to his new team
just super accountability you know
holding you know maybe at the end of
practice when i'm doing my jug machines
you know bring the whole group over to
see the drug machine that way every guy
in the group know hey we're going we
counting on you to make that catch you
know i'm i'm there watching you work
making that catch too because when we
all there we're there together so
you know bringing some of the principles
and some of the things that
make good camaraderie and build good
teams some of the things i know just you
know whatever needed you know being here
being a leader
and um
taking hold of this thing
full full rounded
i had to laugh when he said super
accountability because i i can't think
of another guy with a greater disconnect
between legendary work ethic on the
field
and chronic inability to show up for
work on time right that's not super
accountability and and it you know i i
like the the two characteristics don't
mesh if you are wired to bust your ass
every day no matter what at work
you're also wired to show up on time i
can't think of anyone who once they get
to work they're going to work harder
than anyone but good luck getting them
to show up at work when you want them to
show up
that's right we'll you know i guess what
we should we should clarify it and make
it simpler he is a legendary worker when
it comes to walking out on the practice
field right i don't think anybody's
going oh man he's amazing in the meeting
room i mean you should see him whoa yeah
no i think he looks at the meeting
sometimes he just goes [ __ ] come on i
know how to i know these players i know
how to run a slant i'll get there when i
get there and then i'll show them on the
field how good i am and how i know all
these plays and they'll understand and
hey uh yes so so from that i i giggled
too here's the thing chris here here's
what i don't understand right right
because there's valuable information
being conveyed in the meeting room yes
what if you pick up that one little
thing that you didn't previously think
of because you are paying attention
right and it helps you in a key moment
in a key game right like maybe not
running the hot route and a walk through
at practice and the quarterback getting
a little angry and then you're mad at
the quarterback because he got angry
even though it was your fault you didn't
know it was a hot route i mean that's
where it all started in pittsburgh i
mean anybody you talked to that's where
the star the story started and that's
about accountability and maybe talking
and listening and and knowing some of
those little nuances that maybe have
just been implemented in the offense
earlier that day in the meeting or
whatever it may be so yes your points
are valid um
he he but he's accountable as far as
work ethic on the field he's accountable
as far as love of playing football and
john gruden is the type of coach and
listen this goes on everywhere in the
nfl except for new england because they
can get away with it hey star players
get away with more than the third string
middle linebacker who just plays special
teams sorry that's the way the world
works in any business you know the star
at any company gets away with a little
wiggle room compared to the guys at the
lower level so that goes out and john
gruden's not afraid to kind of play to
that because he knows the guy's a baller
when the lights turn on you know john
gruden's gonna love we heard they might
have had a meeting yesterday going over
plays right mike i mean john's gonna eat
that up he's sitting there talking to a
receiver and they're talking ball and
they're talking little things like that
to where if antonio is three minutes
late one day he's gonna brush it to the
side because he's gonna know the guy
loves football and he's here to work
the story you told or the example you
gave reminded me of the story of jimmy
johnson cutting a player who fell asleep
in the meeting room when he was coached
the cowboys and somebody asked him what
would you do if troy aikman fell asleep
he said i'd get him a pillow
mike that's exactly right let's just
think about bill belichick right nobody
breaks the rules well before he was bill
belichick you know five six-time winning
super bowl uh head coach when he was the
defensive coordinator for the new york
giants there was a sleeping bag at his
feet during meetings you know why
because lawrence taylor he was gonna
rest that because he might have been out
that night before with some
extracurricular activities and didn't
sleep a whole lot so they let him sleep
sit down and rest on the floor while the
meeting was going on you know why they
let him do that because he was freaking
lawrence taylor and there's a good
chance he was gonna get three sacks that
week so they were gonna deal with it but
here's we gotta take a break but you
know what was it belichick or was it
parcells well did belichick be did
belichick take that example and say when
i'm the guy we're not gonna have this
kind of stuff we're not going to have
this separate set of rules it's going to
be the same rules for everyone so that's
something we can have a discussion about
another day
i just wonder how much of that was right
bill belichick versus bill parcell
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports